hello folks and welcome to rational
science
we have another session today what's
different about this site
well what do we do here is
physics
and other people say they do physics but
they do
mathematics
what is mathematics mathematics is the
movement of
concepts okay they move abstractions
or like mr bourne said once the 1920 i
think
1960s sorry
he said that
physics was becoming more abstract
but it turns out that abstraction or
abstract is the opposite of physical
so physics has to do with the physical
and abstract has to do with whatever the
opposite of physical is
and so you figure it out what
mathematical physics does is
abstractions
and here we do real physics the only
side on the internet really
we model
everything with physical objects
now
people will say well that sounds like
classical physics
and yeah uh you could say that i mean
classical physics
considered particles to be real core
puzzles
you know like dusts of sand or uh
uh you know
any particle any corpuscle
uh what you would think is a little ball
of something
right
and that faded away with quantum
mechanics a lot of people are not aware
of that
they ask questions as if they
they hear the word particle
and they think that particle refers to
you know what everybody understands for
the word particle it's a little speck of
dust or a grain of sand
that's not what a particle is anymore
you say
what is a particle
well particle is a wave function
uh
and what is a wave function well you see
the wave function is an equation
and
so what is a particle
well the wave function collapses
and turns into a dot
and that's what they call the particle
an equation that collapses and turns
into a dot
so you can see that we're a little
farther away from physics now there are
no physical interpretations
which is what the common man out there
wants to understand because he doesn't
understand all that math he wants to
understand
what you get out of it you know what's
the bottom line
and the bottom line is you know you
would think that they have the
mathematicians
that they have an explanation for how
this universe works how does gravity
work how does magnetism work
and he said they said
and the wave function collapsed
and he said oh
i missed that you know this is over my
head
what did you mean by that well we well
you got to take math
you know university math to really
you know
understand what we're saying
there are no physical interpretations
it coming out of emanating out of
mathematical physics that's the bottom
line okay
and so uh you know when people like in
quora they ask questions they want to
know how the universe works the common
man wants to know that that's all he
wants to know and these people give him
the run around they say look you gotta
have this equation this equation proves
this
and what they give them is a description
and an irrational explanation for that
equation
because they can only provide irrational
explanations if they you model the their
theory with particles
that's the whole issue
and until you understand that
you know known you have no idea what
science is about today what physics
so-called physics is about today
anyways we start our first uh half of
our lecture
with
subject matter related to
extinction the extinction of man
what are we talking about well we're
talking about um i'm saying that in this
channel right we say that we are the
last humans on earth
last generation of humans on earth
whatever generation means to you
we've got very little time to live
we're not going to live decades we're
not going to live centuries
we're about to die as a species we're
going to become extinct
together with all the other mammals
this is the end of man and
uh people have say
bill you know you're a little
pessimistic
no i drink beer and wine i can't be
pessimistic
no i'm realistic that's what it's called
okay
uh i'm i'm urging you to get your feet
underground
and maybe this is not a good idea if you
want to live life maybe you should
forget about what i say in this channel
it's not a very popular channel in that
sense you don't want to
believe in the theory you want to
believe that maybe you get 100 years in
front of you
but you know
one thing is having a false sense of
security
and another one is reality and so what
i'm saying i'm not pessimistic i'm
realistic
okay
and
some people would rather
listen and learn the what the theory is
about and other people dismiss it all
together and say no no no i don't want
to even hear it
okay
your choice you know that's why no
problem with me anyways here we have
some news
it's got to do with this bug called
omicron
what the hell is omicron
well it's a variant of covid
you know we had the alpha beta zeta
whatever
delta and now we have the omegron and
i'm sure there's going to be a couple
more
and that means we have all these
variants okay
and the new one is omicron and now
they're going to shut down the world
apparently in some place especially here
in europe i'm in germany
i think they're going to be shutting
down
europe
during the winter
and what i mean by that is you know um
international travel is going to be a
problem
and hotels is going to be a problem
restaurants are going to be a problem
anything that has to do with leisure
like physical leisure where you
go with your personal body you know
is gonna be
switched off
okay
and uh i don't know if that's a good
idea okay
but anyways let's get on with the
headline here it says the following says
um uk economy slows
in third quarter before arrival of
omicron
in other words before the uh omicron
already the uk economy
was uh apparently
having some problems
but that's not why i put this article
here i put it because of what it says in
in you know i just pulled out these
snippets out of there it says
in output terms the largest contributors
to the increase in quarter three were
what hospitality
arts
entertainment and recreation
and in contrast production and what
construction both fell
and also they say motor vehicles fell
for the third quarter uh consecutive
and what is this telling us that means
uh
the whole global economy
really because this is england right in
the uk or united kingdom
but the issue here is that all these
advanced nations have this exactly the
same problem so what we see here is
really a microcosm of all of europe
all of the western world
perhaps although the planet okay
you have countries in south america i
was talking about argentina the other
day
i'm sure countries in africa have
similar problems
what are they all experiencing well
they're all experiencing the same exact
thing no matter where you go
and that is that everybody is developing
those
uh
non-productive segments of the economy
and what's falling as a percentage of
gdp in every country on the planet
is uh the production the cr
the stuff that produces something
tangible
and it turns out that the tangible stuff
is what creates growth
and i keep giving you that scenario
you and god are next to each other you
know
you're both embracing yourself you're
looking down on the planet down below
right you've got you're up there with
god right you're seeing the whole planet
what do you see
well you see what's being produced
what's physical
you see the houses you see the
highways you see the
bridges you see the ships you see the
cars you see the airplane you see the
tangible stuff you see the fields of
corn the fields of wheat
that's what you see
that's real
that's growth
and what's expanding now is what
hospitality arts entertainment and
recreation
what the hell is that
well that's all this abstract stuff
in fact what what all this really is is
internet
what's expanding is the internet
even at the expense of
manual services such as barbering or
landscaping
what's expanding is the internet
so we're all moving into the internet
and the question is
that i ask foolishly
people don't believe
don't even understand sometimes
uh can we run a world on
leisure
on just abstractions
and
all i can say is food for thought okay
can the world just be run on
abstractions and commercials
that you know ads that they put on the
internet to stimulate the abstractions
that's what we have today that's the
world of today
so yeah um the uh uk economy in in a way
is giving you an idea of what's
happening in the world and why we're
approaching a point where
you know
it's all leisure it's all vacation it's
all fun
you know uh entertainment
can we run the world on entertainment
some people will say that you can
and
i take the opposite field
my five cent's worth
okay anyways i'm going to tell you a
little story today
and it's got to do with uh probably some
of you heard of grant hence christian
anderson
and other people even have never heard
of this story so i have to go through
the story first okay it's got to do with
this omicron thing
okay and it starts like this it says
that there was a king
an emperor
and uh
he
heard about these two weavers that could
weave the best cloth the best
suit
you know the best robe for a king that
you could imagine
and so he wanted to meet these two
fellows okay
and so here's the king meeting the two
fellas okay and they say look we can
make a a rope for you that
will knock you out of your socks
and the king said okay and i kind of
like that challenge uh okay i'll hire
you so
uh they hired them the two uh
follows there they started weaving
and they started weaving
inexistent
invisible intangible threads
and i know people say hey bill that's
your thread there
it's invisible and tangible yeah
yeah don't tell me what i know already
okay so these two weavers they started
weaving intangible threads
and they went through the motions
in fact that they had no threads they
just went through the motions
of weaving thread and making this uh
robe for the king
obviously an invisible intangible um
robe because there was nothing there to
begin with okay
okay so uh the king
you know heard that these guys were
working there said told one of his
ministers you know one of his dukes his
his counts he said go out there and see
what what they're doing i want to see
what the tell me what the road looks
like more or less what it what it's
starting to look like you know because
i'm going to be wearing it in public i
want to know what it looks like and so
one of the guys comes over here and uh
the
the pitch that these two weavers were
saying is that anyone who could not
see the thr robe
was not deserving of their position
in other words here we had
electromagnetic threads
yeah here we have a situation where you
know if you couldn't see the robe if you
couldn't see what they
made
their their argument was that anyone who
could not see it was not deserving of
their position
as a minister as a you know as a
right-hand man of the king of the
emperor
so this guy comes over and he doesn't
see anything
and so he wonders what am i going to
tell the king
he's he's a little worried because he
doesn't see anything but he says
i can't let him know that i don't see
anything because these you know the king
knows already
has been
lectured
has been
led to believe
that anyone who can't see the robe is
not deserving of his position of his job
so he says
oh it looks so wonderful what a
beautiful robe
and then the king sends a second uh
fellow you know and he looks at it and
he says uh same thing he looks at it he
says
could be that i'm not deserving of my
position
you know she says
it's beautiful it's it's exquisite you
know
so he starts believing in the robe and
the king third sends another messenger
you know another fellow uh his right
hand man maybe even his son and he says
uh what do you see there you know i mean
what does it look like is it good uh you
know your other two ministers said it
looks great
and the guy doesn't see anything but he
has to you know play along he says oh
it's just absolutely gorgeous
you know and so saw they all just fell
in for the uh ruse you know they said
yeah the robe is absolutely exquisite
it's great it's lovely
and now it was finally the king's turn
you know the emperor has to come over
and he has to look at it and he also
wonders you know what how beautiful this
robe is that they prepared for him you
know and he goes in there
and he says okay yeah i've come here to
see the robe i see you want to see what
it looks like
and when he looks he can't see anything
and so now we have a problem because you
know the the other fellows behind them
say well nobody can see anything but
everybody has to say that they did and
the king himself he says am i not
deserving of my own job
of course not so he has to fall in line
as well and he said oh it's ravishing
you know it's the greatest thing that
i've ever saw
okay
and so you know the uh story go as the
story goes you know uh the uh
king ends up parading naked around the
city
okay
and it's just a little boy i think his
name is bill gatey
who says uh
the emperor is nude he's got
he's got nothing gone
and you know all everybody just says no
no it's it's a great robe i love it you
know
and the guy's parading naked around the
city
you know so that's uh
that's how the uh story goes i think
it's a great
analogy for what happens in relativity
and mathematical physics and quantum and
strength theory and here's the uh
um
relativity version of this okay
here you have the emperor's tale and
they say it's uh the space time
and people say oh space time looks so
great so beautiful what are all those
dots there oh those are the black holes
and what's all that fuzziness that i see
around the galaxy oh that's dark matter
and yeah you can't see your taste or
touch or any anything with those and the
reason is very simple you know these are
abstract concepts
you know black holes of singularity a
space time is what space and time
is time of physical object
and dark matter is just a bunch of
particles you know just a concept there
and so yeah these are concepts that's
the problem okay with this
so-called theory of
relativity
and then you have uh you know the
quantum
also the
the
quantum fields the people they have
their own tail looks more or less like
this uh it's the wave function tail
you know and again people say well
what are you staring at what was staring
at a wave
and what's a wave well it's this
function that has you know fields and
two fields and
what flows in one direction is energy
and all these are concepts and obviously
you can't see them
but you have to make
believe
go through the motions of believing that
they exist and that you can see them
okay and here we have uh richard feynman
he says he's going bongo over this
yeah no kidding
okay yeah you gotta go bongo with this
nonsense of um
talking about uh
abstractions
and turning them into physical objects
and you say bill what does this have to
do with omicron
well we have the same situation with
omnicron with this virus okay
and all i can show you is is the
following
okay
here's uh
the
the two
weavers and they say here's the omicron
bug
the virus
do you believe in it
can you see it
can you touch it are you aware of it do
you believe in the theory or do you
accept the theory do you understand the
theory
okay that's the issue here
and uh yeah here you have um
the clovid flowchart to get down to the
bottom of this issue
there's uh people out there who will
tell you that
this omicron not even omiground the
covid
is a
hoax
it's not real
it's uh something run by the politicians
the illuminati et cetera et cetera the
new world order people the people who
rule the world
the the filthy rich you know
and this is a hoax
you don't have to believe this
covet thing don't get too shocked
you know it's probably going to do more
damage to you than anything that you
ever thought about
and so i created this copic flow chart
to to get to the bottom of this i mean
if you're
really honest with yourself if you're
objective and you really want to get to
the bottom of it
you might want to follow at least some
of these steps in the flow chart
okay
and
you know we we
bring back
to life mr alhazen
and he said you know whenever you
analyze a theory
the first thing you have to do
especially with those theories you
believe in
is
attack your theories
with the utmost vehemence
you know become an enemy of your own
theories
okay
and so if you can attack your own theory
with everything you've got with
everything you can think of
and you come out on top after that
then at least you know that you can
defend your theory
from anyone who can attack it because
you have
more or less you know resolved all the
arguments okay
but if you just have a belief and say
well i don't believe in the coping i
don't believe that this is real i think
it's a hoax
well maybe you have an
unsubstantiated belief
because you have no backing for your
theory
okay so what i'm suggesting is you
follow the flow chart it's i think a
minimum
required of anyone who really wants to
be
honest and get to the bottom of
you know his uh his beliefs
if you're going to hold a belief
of a theory right of an explanation
i think you should more or less follow
this flowchart okay
recommendation
okay and so the first question is is
there an object called a virus
you know some people don't even believe
that there are viruses out there
so obviously you cannot talk to them
about a an omicron or a whatever uh
covet virus
because they don't even believe that
there are viruses out there they don't
even know what these
researchers or doctors or health workers
are talking about what do you mean
what's this
virus
thingy that you're talking about
okay so let's get that one
settled
okay
this is what you see
under the scanning electron microscope
now i was certified on a scanning
electron microscope i knew how to run it
i would see things not of this nature i
would see
uh semiconductor chips
very tiny chips transistors that kind of
thing
but i i understand what a semi uh
one of these sems is a scanning electron
microscope there is a more powerful one
known as the atomic force microscope
and this is what they see under the
scope under these high power
scopes
you know here you see all these
different types of viruses
now you don't want to call them virus
you want to call them x i don't care
there's something there okay
and so for you to say that this is not
there
it just shows ignorance that's all it is
because this is like the flat earther
saying that the earth is flat
you know if the earth is round
and spherical and you say that is flat
or that black is white
you know that on is off
uh well you're
you're just being uh
either ignorant
foolish you know you just look up the
words now you have to look at this and
say you got to give these things a name
they see these things under the scope
okay you don't have to believe in what
they are you know you have you may have
all the theories you want but you have
to recognize that these things are
things that they see under the scope
under the scanning electron microscope
okay
so whatever name you give these thingies
i don't care they call them viruses you
can't say that the virus does not exist
okay that's my first argument
so uh
if you say know that you don't believe
in viruses well you
go to jail and you don't collect 200.
okay
that's my take on that
now do the viruses cause disease
and that's a big if
not everybody agrees
and there i can't tell you much because
you know i'm not in that field and
there's a field i'm not very much
interested in i've said that in the past
okay but i'm just saying that this is
those people who are interested in the
subject
these are the questions you should ask
yourself and go do the research you know
make sure that you understand
uh
what you're rooting for
okay
if you believe that
viruses don't exist you have a problem
because there is something under the
scope now do you think those little
balls that you see in there they cause
disease that's the second question okay
and uh here's one fellow and he pointed
me to a
video
and he says look at this video bill
okay so i watched a little bit i haven't
watched all of it because i get the
sense of it in the first uh
i think the video ran like 45 minutes i
i saw only like 35 minutes and there
were two more videos of this stuff so i
didn't go through all of it but this was
the
overall picture for from the first half
hour okay
uh fellow this uh dr trent he says
there's lots of diseases that are caused
by environmental factors
such as pollution sewers hygiene etc
okay
vaccines are developed in rodents and
monkeys but these animals carry other
viruses
that are later passed on to you with a
vaccine
you know sometimes the manufacturing
process is not careful enough some of
these other viruses that
you know belong to these monkeys these
rodents they're passed on to you with a
vaccine and they say well this is the
vaccine this is the covid vaccine we
give you the shot and you get you know
the other viruses that you never
bargained for
could happen yeah i can i can at least
understand what he's saying i can
imagine that it could happen
um it is another notion that this doctor
was saying is is not wise to elect the
public
about all that's involved in vaccine r d
and manufacturing because it might
create a panic in other words the common
man does not always understand what's
going on in the research centers
and he might imagine more than what's
there
and imagine the worst
and so governments uh are careful with
the information that reaches the public
and the establishment the health
establishment
sometimes says don't tell this to the
public
because if you tell the public they
don't really understand they're gonna go
into panic they're not gonna want the
vaccine
and they're just gonna be doing more
damage to themselves
than what it's worth the vaccine is good
but these people you know are going to
interpret it in the wrong way so we
might as well not give them the
information
and other doctors who are aware of the
information says ah they're hiding the
information because they know it's gonna
uh scare the public why because the
public is gonna be aware that there are
problems
and so it's uh damned if you do endeavor
if you don't situation
and that's what this doctor was saying
one of the arguments he raised he says
that the establishment doesn't always
want to give information to the public
okay
and then another issue is critics are
systematically silenced on
or given a career redirection
yeah
there were people like mrs eddie if you
look her up eddy
and uh
she criticized a lot of these
investigations these r d's these
researches and the conclusion they draw
drew from them
and
she was given new assignments saying uh
we need you over here
so they pulled her out put her in
another place where she caused less of a
trouble and there's a lot of
whistleblowers
within the health industries not a lot
but there's always a percentage of them
that say you know
i think these people are lying i think
these people are not doing the right
thing they're not telling the public
what's really going on
and
you know what the health officials say
look you're in the way because if you
tell that to the public you're going to
create this bigger
monster than what we're trying to do
here and so they move them away or they
try to silence them etc
and more or less what's happening in the
mathematical
physics establishment where you know
anyone who opposes that
is considered a
dissident
uh meaning that you're considered a nerd
you know you're considered a
a person who's not in tune
with a mathematical establishment okay
and so they move you aside they don't
even pay attention to you they censor
you because you're opposing the
establishment
i know a little bit about that because
i've been there 20 years and so i can
sympathize with them
with these uh people who oppose the
establishment now whether
you do more damage in the health
industry than you do in the mathematical
establishment where they're dealing with
theories
abstract theories of how this universe
works i think those situ two situations
are different okay but yeah i can
understand that some people on the
inside
uh see uh
things that they don't like
and that they think are anti um
or not in the public interest
and so they want a whistleblower they
want to you know
tattletail on on what the establishment
is doing and one of them was again
my mom she she worked in the
in a hospital and she worked later on
with a dentist and she
saw things that she didn't like at all
you know a lot of commercialism
uh
the
drug peddler coming over to the doctor
saying sell this drug for me and you'll
get a 10 bonus and that kind of thing
and so
she saw a lot of things she didn't like
and so yeah i can understand a little
bit about this it's human nature that's
how we all are you know
okay another one case histories of
people who got this or that vaccine
and succumbed to the disease anyways and
then you have the vaccines such as polio
uh turning this all caused cancer
so you know you have all this stuff and
you listen to a guy like him
and the question is should you believe
him or should you take what he says is a
grain of you know with a grain of salt
uh what should you do you know unless
you're uh it really in the business
it's kind of like weird
what should you do what should you
believe
and you have all this information out
there
and you have two sides to the question
you have the establishment and if you
don't like your establishment oh they're
lying
you may be choosing the wrong side you
know i mean i can't tell you
all i can say is that
there's a lot of politics involved a lot
of interests involved and that gets in
the way of the
truth okay whatever the truth is
okay
um
here you have uh how the virus really
works
okay
it makes copies of itself right
and uh inside the cell and then uh
pollutes other cells
this is how the
this is the theory right behind it
do you believe in this theory well you
know again it's uh
it depends on
on you
if if you're gonna believe this or not
you know and then if you do believe that
this is what happens
the question is um
whether
what you're going to do about it
how do you think this should be cured
assuming you believe that viruses exist
viruses cause disease
viruses uh there is this virus called
covid which is different than all the
others
okay
and
then assuming you accept all that right
are you going to take that next step and
ask the question what should we do about
it
and these people the
health
experts
they've decided that the way to combat
it is through um
chemically in other words you create a
uh
what is known as a vaccine
and they're gonna inject it to you it's
gonna create antibodies so that if the
virus hits you
you know you
are in contact with the virus and it
enters your body
and it tries to attack your cells
well then uh this anti these antibodies
work to help
prevent that they attacked this virus
now the virus is not a living entity and
i you know you have a lot of doctors out
there that don't even understand that
and that's what because they never
define what life is what a living entity
is
biology to this day has not done that
across the planet
no university on the planet no
biologists on a planet has defined the
word
life they say well as that was
reproduced his sleeves
uh takes a dump every morning and
they they talk about what the thing does
and they try to define it in based on
what a thing does
and actually you know
it is what a thing does but there's only
one common
factor and that's that they all any
living entity moves against gravity
actually it moves against the path of
least resistance that's the formal
definition we propose but the primary
issue is gravity if you can move against
gravity
you're not a rock
you're not in a inert
thing okay
so that's the bottom line and the
question is you know a virus is just a
molecule it's a little round
ball-like
molecule not always in the case of the
rabies
virus it's like a cylinder
right there are different types of
viruses but the point is it's an inert
molecule a very complex molecule
built with
proteins etc and what it does is once it
enters the
uh cell
inside the cell it uses the cell
material living material it eats it up
from the inside and makes copies of
itself
that later on sprout and infect other
cells and do the same thing to those
cells
that's the theory
whether you believe it or not that is
the theory okay and so the question is
do you think that's what this covet
thing does
and if you decide that it does that
that's what the theory is and you think
it's a good theory unless someone
produces something different right out
there
well then you have to conclude that you
gotta attack it somehow you have to
address it somehow and the way these
health
professionals have decided that they're
gonna attack it is through
chemistry they're going to create a
vaccine which
creates antibodies within your body
that's
essentially a chemical process
and if the bug comes you come in contact
with a bug then you have defenses
against it they will attack that virus
meaning they're going to break the
molecule up
or they're going to render it inert or
whatever okay they're going to
neutralize it
that's the theory okay
okay
so you know the uh i'm just saying that
that's the checklist that any rational
person anyone who wants to reach
to the bottom of the issue wants to be
objective about it
uh you should
ask those questions to yourself
do the research on those topics at least
maybe you've got some better questions
no problem but the issue is you have to
attack your own beliefs
then you know you're solid in your
beliefs but to say well i don't think
there's any bug out there i don't think
that
uh
there is such a thing as coving or that
it causes disease i think this is just a
a thing from the
from the ruling classes
so far you have said
nothing to a rational individual
okay it's not a question of belief
it's a question of do your research as
much as possible you know and find out
whether you are solid that you can
present an argument
an argument for each one of these
questions
are there viruses yes or no
is a virus
does it virus cause disease
is there such a thing as a covert virus
and if you say yes to all those then the
question is
you know what should we do about it
okay
okay moving on here uh
here we have another
situation we have the international
business times that says
who you know the world health
organization sees unprecedented omicron
spread probably in most countries and
the eu is to decide on new kobe jab as
omicron rages
you know and there you have the coffins
in germany one picture that they show
like saying uh you know
uh beware this thing is out there it's
gonna kill you and so this is a little
bit of fear-mongering okay you see all
these cases in one week
uh
in uh the entire planet okay there
uh and so the question is you know here
you have another
side of that story that came out
uh the other day that i pointed out to
it says the omicron variant you know
considerable protection against severe
disease is maintained they're saying
that
they're saying that the omicron
is out there right
but you don't have to worry too much
about it if you have at least two
shots already two jabs because it
already protects you more or less
against this omnicron as far as they can
tell
and at the bottom you say omicron no
need for a very specific booster at this
time
okay so why are they raising so much
hell
about this omicron if the two vacs that
i got you know i got on my shoulder
and i think it was in this one i can't
remember anymore uh you know the
the two shots that i got apparently
defend me or protect me against
the omicron
you know there's a new variant called
the omnicron apparently
other than two or three
modifications you know mutations it's
got like 10
mutations over the delta
or
at least to the original
uh covet i can't i can't remember which
one but the point is there's more
variations in the new strain known as
omicron
okay great
i don't care i mean
does the
or do the two vaccines that i got
protect me against the omnicron yes or
no it's a black or white issue
and these people are saying yes they do
that apparently it you know softens the
blow or whatever
so why are we developing a new vaccine
against the omicron
why are we
uh closing the entire planet again
apparently we're starting for this
new uh winter session
closing up uh
all these places restaurants hotels
tourism etc
uh why are we closing everything down if
the omicron is just a variant of the
delta or of the covid original cobit the
alpha whatever it's called
and
whatever vaccine you have in you is
sufficient to protect you against the
omicron
you know why are we raising a panic
again
in the world of economics because
there's a health issue
and like i covered last time you know
right now russia showed 16 cases
cuba showed four
and other countries show you know very
few we're talking about
eight billion people
being locked down because four people
have
a disease
which apparently hasn't killed them yet
there was one case apparently in london
in england where one person died
should we stop the entire planet because
one person died
and some people
a handful you know we're talking about
10 20 people
have the new omicron variant
and they get maybe sick or maybe they
don't even get sick they don't even know
they had it
should we shut down the global economy
because of this
this is where you have to stop and think
is this uh
real or not
is there something else going on is this
politics
you know
okay changing the subject
that was food for thought
fellow says is this norm uh i said is
this normal and a fellow says please
define normal bill
you know define it first
and what am i talking about well i was
talking about these people who
are born
with x y
and they change their sex they continue
to be xy but they want to be xx double x
okay
we have missed pronouns
uh
his name was like tommy and they called
her sally at the miss universe context
representative from nevada we had
victoria's secret representative
and the secret was that
he was a
she was a he
and we have these fellows who are you
know
ex-wives fighting ex-sexism people
especially women who are fighting in
those categories a little upset because
they say these guys you know
uh
during their puberty they were
xyz you know they developed these
muscles
uh based on you know testosterone and
now they
inject uh
estrogen in themselves to grow boobs and
whatever
you know are these males or females
should they fight against females and so
we have all this situation these days
and it's kind of weird so this fellow
says
bill define normal if you say that
you know is this normal i mean what do
you mean by that
and all i can tell you is i i have
defined the term in the past okay i have
defined the term and so let me go over
the word normal again
okay
and
this is the analogy so that you
understand what i mean by normal in this
context okay
and you go to the river
and you see some
swans
and they're all white
and suddenly you see a black swan go by
he said whoa
i thought all swans were white
and here's this
black swan completely black swan
oh this is not normal
well is it
well it turns out you do a census of all
the swans in the world
and you find out that ten percent of
them are black
nothing racial here is just that it's a
fact okay uh
ten percent of the swans in the world
are black
so it turns out that if you see a black
swan among
i don't know nine swans
well it's normal it's normal because ten
percent
of the global schwanns are black
that's what you call normal
but what happens
when you do a study and you say okay in
the year 1990 there were 10 percent
of the global
swans that were black
in the year 2000 it was 11 percent
in the year 2010 it was 15 percent
in the year 2020 it was 20 percent
of the swans of black
well now we have a problem
not really a problem what we have is
we have an uh uh phenomenon we have to
explain
why are the number of black swans
increasing
as a percentage of the global population
are all swans becoming black
and so you have to answer that question
this is no longer normal
normal now is is out the door because
you're saying
something is happening and it needs to
be explained
now
in the case of the color of swans it may
not make much of a
difference but in the case of
homosexuality
it might make a little bit of difference
i mean if the number of homosexuals
are increasing as a percentage of the
population year by year by year
not only is it not
normal
but we got a bigger problem this is not
a cosmetic problem where the color of
our skin is changing
we have a problem where you know we have
people who are not going to be
reproducing
because they're not interested in the
opposite sex with which
they're going to be
creating you know another human being so
this has to do with population
increase right with a
rate of population growth
so now we have to address this issue is
this
is
is this normal the fact that
not only people are converting to the
opposite sex but that there are ever
more of these people converting to the
opposite sex
and you know uh in 1973
you had the site american psychiatry
association later on three years later
we had the psychology association
american psychology association doing
the same thing
they declared that homosexuality was
normal
in other words they took it out of the
list
of mental
problems
okay
later on the world health organization
did the same thing following their cue
and the question is why did they do that
was it because they decided that
homosexuality was
normal quotations
no the problem was that
you know in the last few years prior to
1973
you know hundreds and thousands of
homosexuals invaded the
psychiatry association the psychiatrist
the shrinks
and they said doctor cure me i got a
problem yeah what's your problem well
i'm homosexual
and what was a doctor gonna give him a
pill to cure them
and when they had so many people come to
them they said look we got to do
something about this
and they finally decided hey we got the
solution
let's say they have no problem period
we're done
we have no pill to give them nothing to
that will overcome their homosexuality
so let's accept them let's just say that
it's no longer a mental disorder
so they took it out of the list of
mental disorders and they say you guys
are free you guys are okay as long as
you don't have a problem with yourself
you're okay
that was the decision taken by the
psychiatric association
but why did they do that because they
had more and more and more and more
cases
they had to
turn it into something normal because
they said well you know it can't be that
10 12 15 20 of the population is
homosexual
we'll just call it normal what what the
idea was and the way this thing
developed was that
history or historically they had
silenced
homosexuality saying you know if you're
a homosexual you're mistreated
the law goes against you we punish you
and so these people remain in the dark
and now that we have a little more
you know flexibility in the law
uh these people could come out of the
closet and all we're doing is just
seeing more cases
because
of the law not because of something that
happens in the biological world
they were always there now they just
came out of the closet that was the
overall
notion
but was that the case
is it that these people were always
i don't know 10 15 20 of the population
or is it that
the numbers have increased over the last
few years
and that's for you to judge okay
so
until that question is answered
the psychiatry association of the united
states
uh really uh never answered the question
they just said we're going to consider
it normal because we've seen all these
cases
and the question is you know if this was
a private uh
issue between
the patient and the doctor the
psychiatrist the shrink
then we had an increase
in people coming out of the wombs of
women
which had
this
we'll call it a mental disorder until
then right they had a mental problem
that's why they came to see the doctor
they say i got a problem doc
you know i like men i'm a man and i like
men
so they had a problem
they go to see the doctor the shrink the
numbers increase
and the doctors instead of saying oh
this is not normal
instead of concluding that more
homosexuals are coming out of the wombs
of females they decided oh this is
normal they've always been there
and the only change is that now they're
coming out of the closet
it's up for you to decide okay that's
that's the issue there
and so yeah what i'm saying is normal is
if there's in
if it's always remains the same the same
percentage you can say that's normal if
there's an increment
then you have to explain it you can't
say it's
normal
no and especially in this case because
remember
the purpose of sex is not like what the
homosexual lobby wants to spread out
there that is for fun
mother nature invented sex
not for pleasure
if you get pleasure out of it hey more
power to you no problem
and that's good but the issue here is
that sex was invented for exclusively
and only for procreation
two homosexuals whether two females two
males they cannot reproduce
they have to go to the sperm bank or you
know get a
hire a womb somewhere you know
that's the only way
but
two of the same sex cannot reproduce
therefore we have a problem because it's
a violation of nature
what mother nature intended
it has nothing to do with pleasure it
has to do with procreation and to
homosexuals cannot reproduce no matter
how you twist and turn it
you got to do it artificially you got to
go get a third party
the donor of the sperm or the donor of
the womb
you know in order to have a baby
and of course
the question is whether this trend
of people becoming homosexuals or
changing their sexes is normal
and if we have more and more of these
every day
is this normal what is it leading to
and under the theory of extinction yeah
it goes against extinction because it i
mean
it's part of the extinction process why
because
um
you can imagine that we're gonna be
producing fewer children if
we're becoming more and more if a bigger
percentage of the population is becoming
more homosexual
okay so that's the theory that's
that's the notion
okay uh moving on here we have uh foul
says no life can uh travel interstellar
it is forbidden by father universe
that's my statement and if el says
don't give your opinions give us your
theory
this is where you do rational science
remember
uh yeah and i have explained that i in
fact uh have a video yes uh you can look
it up it's called the pioneering anomaly
and it's in playlist under gravity
and it'll explain my theory but in a
nutshell essentially is
uh you know every atom in your body
okay
is bound to every atom
in the universe
let me repeat that because maybe that
hasn't sunk
an atom is something we can't even see
uh in case of the hydrogen atom you're
talking about three angstroms
something you know
you can't even see it under the
microscope
okay you can't see it under the
sun you can't see it under a scanning
electron microscope you cannot see a
hydrogen atom that's how small this
thing is okay
and
one of these guys
is bound to every atom in the universe
i hope that sinks in
i mean in the galaxy in our galaxy we
don't even know how many stars there are
billions of stars
each one
with a solar system like ours maybe you
know with uh planets rolling around
and there are billions
billions of galaxies
so we're talking about uh let's bring
carl sagan back in
billions and billions and billions
okay
we're talking about a big number
so one atom is connected to every atom
in the universe when one atom i mean
even in your room you have billions of
atoms
okay so
alone just one atom in your in your body
is connected to billions of atoms in in
the uh in your room
let alone billions of atoms
in the solar system billions of atoms
in the galaxy billions of atoms in all
the galaxies
i hope that sinks in okay it's a big
number
and so people say oh such a big number
yeah and so if an atom is bound to every
atom in the universe
okay
uh you can see what
implications that has
okay
an atom is made of
the threads coming from every atom in
the universe
so yeah uh what can i say uh if you're
going to be traveling out of the solar
system like this fellow uh wonders right
your atom every atom in your body is
connected to every atom in the sun let's
just talk about the sun obviously the
earth jupiter
mars the whole works let's just talk
about the sun every atom in your body is
tied to every atom in the sun how many
atoms are there in the sun have you
counted them
gazillions
every atom in your body is
bound to every atom in the sun by
gazillions of ropes
i hope that sinks in maybe it doesn't
people it's a number so big that it just
breaks your mind
but that's not the point the point is
the following you
you run away from the sun which is the
biggest mass in the solar system right
the biggest mass is the sun
it's got all these atoms more atoms than
all the planets put together
jupiter
neptune the whole works
so you're running away from this going
to alpha centauri then they're a star
which is just barely a
petty 4.3 light years away
meaning if you travel at the speed of
light you get there in 4.3 light in 4.3
years
300 000 kilometers per second you get
there 4.3 years
so it's far away
from you from a human perspective from
our everyday ex perspective so you're
running away from the sun
the farther away you get all those ropes
what happens to them well they kind of
you know move
into a single coaxial
they kind of you know uh come together
the farther farther away you are from
the sun
and then there's this region this long
region until you get to alpha centauri
proxima
being the first star right
and until you get there you know you get
this long region 4.3
light years that's a measure of distance
in which you know since you have a
straight
coaxial
so there's no gravity you don't have
neutronian gravity newtonian gravity is
only what i call the bird speak
the region
coming out of the solar system
where the ropes are still in a
triangular manner kind of you know
coming into
what i call the linear regime okay
so during that period that you approach
the linear regime yeah you have the um
uh
inverse square of the distance function
but when you get to the linear regime
there is no gravity
now you go straight ahead you drift
to the other star
with whatever you know impact is
whatever
impulse you had from the solar system
from your boosters or whatever
so uh yeah you can't travel to the
nearest star because you'll never make
it not alive
okay
and so
well you gotta watch the the video to
get the feel for it but that's in a
nutshell
what the video says
moving on here next issue
okay it says thou says it is an
imperative for science to fully
understand consciousness
you know i
i'm gonna roll over my tomb anyone who
says consciousness i hate the word
i don't want that word in science at all
anyone who says consonant is talking
about religion
especially eastern religion so you know
get that out of my sight anyways the
final frontier absolutely not has
nothing to do with anything we know that
it can't be just nothing
when we so-called die that can just
happen because of the can't just happen
because of the first law of
thermodynamics energy will only alter
so he's suggesting that this
consciousness is uh energy
and it turns out energy is a concept
okay so what have we learned that we
have this concept called consciousness
but he thinks it's a thing it's not
nothing meaning it's something
meaning it's an object
under the
definition of object of course anyone
who has a different version of the word
object is welcome to
put put it forth okay
anyways this uh energy i'm sorry um
consciousness is is not nothing meaning
it's something meaning it's an object
it's a thing
and then he reinforces that by saying
that it's energy meaning that it's
under the mathematical physics notion
it's something
we're not talking about nothing we're
talking about a thing an object a body
okay that's what they're saying
the library experiment not only put free
full
uh
will free will into question it
demonstrates consciousness is not local
to the body
meaning
this thing stands out parallel to the
body
we have this consciousness
you know out here
okay
our consciousness can affect affect the
outcome of experiments
so not only the consciousness leaves
your body it's in your body it it has a
separate uh
existence
outside the body but now it's going to
affect the
experiment this energy flows the spirit
flows and it's going to affect your
experiment what experiment well
especially the double slit experiment
some people believe in this stuff it's
unbelievable that
they they truly believe that to this day
i mean we're in the 21st century and
these people are in the
days of uh you know the fourth century
where the
monastic uh
uh
era was in its
heyday and
you know they they believe that in
spirits and souls
in uh these phantoms these things that
go to heaven or hell
that they survived the body
you know uh some people believe that the
body weighs
more
when uh when it's alive dying and that
when it's dead
uh it's like they weighs more less and
they say it's because this spirit this
energy
this ghost
leaves the body
so what are they saying are they saying
that there's a spirit that has
shape
maybe made out of atoms some kind of
holy atoms
because it has weight
it's a
body
that has i hate to say but shape
it's an object it's a thing
that comes out of the body
the
real body the you know
one uh made of uh
meat of flesh
is there such a thing these people
believe in this 21st century
they believe that consciousness
comes out of the body and is a thing no
obviously you know rational people
you know just scratch their heads they
say what is this guy talking about
no the so-called spirit
soul consciousness mind thought
dream
nightmare whatever you want to call it i
don't care
is a verb
there's no physical object called
consciousness that you can bring to me
and put on the table because
the definition of a thing is that which
has shape
so no um
this guy said it's nothing no
not nothing he said no it's a
it's nothing
it's not nothing meaning a thing
it's nothing
there's no such thing as consciousness
uh thing is that which has shape
consciousness doesn't have shape
consciousness is it's worse it's it's a
verb it's a concept
and so for people to turn this concept
this thingy like they did in the
traditional religions turning into the
soul
the spirit that goes to heaven or the
hell depending on how nice it was you
know if it's black or white
it's nonsense obviously it's nonsense to
a rational individual but irrational
people believe in the stuff
and regarding the slit experiment that's
got a very simple solution under
rationality
you don't have to believe it but we do
have an explanation here it is
that's the explanation for
uh you know the slit experiment what are
we saying we're saying that if you shine
a light through
monochromatic light right uh if you sign
shine monochromatic light through two
slits very narrow et cetera et cetera uh
you're gonna get what you see on the
right you're gonna see a spreading out
of the ropes
okay that are
binding
the uh two of the atoms there's this is
just an example right just a sample
microcosm of what's happening we're
taking two atoms on the sides of the
needle right
and we're saying that they're connected
to all of the atoms on the screen
and so you have this situation where you
know they're offset by some some so much
of a link
and because of this tiny offset you
create these
fringes these different patterns
so it's very simple under the rope model
it's only under mathematical physics
where they have big problems with this
they can't explain it
and that's because they try to do it
with math and with particles
that's the whole problem we don't need
math we don't need particles particles
cannot explain this phenomenon you have
to explain it with something which is
elongated and binds the atoms of the
needle
to
the atoms of the screen and why we use a
needle very simple we use a needle
because you know with a double slit
uh
the notion that the particle folks have
is that the particles bounce against the
uh
window sills
of the slits so they bounce and come in
that's the notion
but if you put a needle there there's
nothing to bounce against
there's no frame there's no window sill
to for the photons to bounce
if you put a needle we still can produce
the pattern on the screen
but now the photons have nothing to
bounce against
and so you would have to
speculate
or assume that the somehow the photon
turns the corner
okay and yeah explain that from a
physical point of view and you can't
that's why they don't have an answer for
that question today another model very
simple every atom
is from the source
is already connected to every atom of
the needle before you turn on the light
and all you did by turning on the light
is just increase the frequency meaning
you shorten the link lengths
bring down the the ropes in other words
the the atoms really because they
receive this impact right they pump at a
different speed now that pumping
sends
the rope that's connected to your eye
receives a frequency that comes within
the visible range
that's all that's happening and then
yeah so what happens is the
that frequency that
link
length
is transmitted to the atoms on the wall
and those are now
pumping at a different speed you know
they're
expanding and contracting
at this almost the speed of light and
sending that frequency to your eye and
that's why you can see it you can see
the fringes
so we have an explanation of
mechanical mechanistic explanation
and that's what mathematical physics
doesn't have even to this day in
explanation for
okay uh another issue related to my
subject that i like so much neanderthals
fell says clothing might not have been
required in africa but it would have
been needed by any uh furless hominins
exposed to cold weather conditions okay
he's saying that the
neanderthals in the arctic region would
have had to have uh
worn clothes
they couldn't have survived otherwise
okay natasha would have needed clothing
of some time to have survived european
and asian winners
tennis events uh were closely related to
neanderthals and would have also
required clothing to survive
is this true
did the neanderthals wear clothes that's
the bottom line that's the question
or they dress like that guy there you
know with furs and whatever or like the
other monkey on the right which monkey
is the correct neanderthal will will the
real neanderthal please stand up
okay let's find out here we have it
these are the neanderthals that
hollywood puts out there and they dress
them all up and so people get used to
these notions
okay and they say yeah we understand
that the neanderthals had to be covered
because it was so cold in those days in
the arctic and so this is what you see
every day and that's what you believe
okay
and so i'm going to modify that a little
bit and here it is okay
let me put it over here
so that we educate you a little bit
800 000 years ago
800 000 years ago before any
neanderthals were alive on earth before
they existed before they came into being
before they evolved
there was a two-legged creature in
london
okay
in happiestburg 800 000 years ago there
was a two-legged individual
certainly an erectus or an
uh
homo antecessor
one of those
maybe heidelberg i i don't care one of
those guys
they were already living in happiestburg
arctic weather
hunting
just look it up
okay
not only have they found footprints they
have found bones of
liquidated
uh mammoths
around the fire
there was some kind of two-legged
creature
did that creature wear clothes
where clothes
invented 800 000 years almost a million
years ago
that's the question for you
okay
and so again you got to do your research
uh
i'm saying that there was no there were
no close eight hundred thousand years
ago there were no close five hundred
thousand years ago there were no clothes
300 000 years ago
clothes were invented in
from my research i can tell you that
clothes were invented around 35 to 40
000 years ago by humans
uh people
clans
that came from africa they drifted into
europe because the neanderthals were no
longer there that's why they could enter
europe
they entered the
neanderthal crawls
so to speak
and they entered their caves they
probably found the narrow holes bones
there dead and they kicked them aside
and say i'm going to live here now
and they say oh it's so cold in here you
know and so they started building
clothes they invented needles
they uh
invented threads they probably put first
together as they moved gradually into
the arctic weathers little by little
they they uh they started you know
weaving clothes or using um
the skins of animals which they sewed
together somehow
okay and so i'm saying that clothes were
invented when humans
the only animal that ever invented
clothes
entered into europe
around 35 to 40 000 years ago
when
the neanderthals were gone neanderthals
were furry animals they were the woolly
man
before then there were the heidelbergs
they were the woolly men and also lived
in arctic weathers before them you have
the either take your pick the homo
erectus or homo
intercessor
whichever one
and they lived in arctic europe
at least 800 000 years ago
and they had no clothes
okay so you figured it out and then uh
just in case you know you have wolves
today they sleep in the snow
and he said huh how can that be
oh you have you heard of the polar bear
uh does he uh hide in the snow and say
oh it's so cold today
no he sleeps in the snow
wall sleep in the snow
the buffalo up there also sleep in the
snow
and you say well humans can't sleep in
the snow
well not us that's our puny
humans you know we have thin skin
nano though they had thick skin because
they came they evolved from the high
doublers who evolved from the homo
erectus or the ancestors
so
they they had already thousands of years
of
acclimatization to the arctic weathers
okay so yeah
hi i'm sorry uh neanderthals never wore
clothes they didn't wore sandals to walk
in the snow oh it's so cold no they they
put their foot feet just like a wolf
does puts his feet directly in the snow
and just
he's used to it
and he's how can it be yeah yeah please
understand that wolves do not wear
sandals
they do not wear boots
shoes anything like anything leather
covering their feet
okay another foul says
you say that human extinction in is
inevitable nothing can be done
um it is nature so it was decided from
the beginning living things at some
point cease to exist
your theory is genetic
no it ain't but let's continue hope is
uh a humane uh feeling of confident
expectation in the realization
present or future of what one desires
desire to live
also a natural mechanism that apparently
contrasts that of planned extinction
mine is not a planned extinction and
what was the other one uh no i'm not
saying that um was it uh
that it's a genetic theory
he's got it all wrong okay so
i want to clarify those two things it's
not genetic
and it's not planned there's no god out
there that says i'm gonna plan
the uh
death of humans
or of any animal for that matter or a
plant
no that's not the way it works the way
it works is that
the facts are
that
periodically all plants
all animals every single species of
plants every species of animal becomes
extinct
i hope that sinks through okay
it must come to an end it comes to an
end why because if it doesn't come to
into
extinct
because of a mass extinction and i'm
just gonna put that one aside it comes
uh to an end through a background
extinction
what's a background extinction
it's the disappearance of one
species
one species alone disappears everyone
else doesn't even notice it everybody
else is doing everything just continues
living as if nothing one species
disappears
how did that one species disappear how
did mother nature select that one
well it selects all of them all of them
will disappear in the same way unless a
mass extinction gets them
how do they disappear
they disappear for two reasons
one is their population pyramid
overturns
and they lose their genetic diversity
after gazillions of years of inbreeding
if you inbreed you lose your genetic
diversity if you lose your genetic
diversity not because of diseases like
those geneticists tell you
if you lose your genetic diversity
you're not going to have children in the
end you're going to stop having children
your children are going to be [ __ ]
which is what's happening today with
humans
we have been inter inbreeding for 200 to
300 000 years since our species has been
on the planet
and what do you think happens after
inbreeding for 200 300 000 years well
you have mental problems you have
physical problems you have children with
six fingers you know i i have to put a
sixth one because i don't have six
fingers
that's what happens you can't have
normal children
after uh extensive inbreeding
so that's the problem it's not a that
you're you're liable to catch a disease
like the geneticists say
notice that two or three generations
down the road you won't have any normal
children
okay that's the issue
and so you know it's not that it's uh
programmed by god or mother nature or
father universe or the devil you know
it's that
you can't continue inbreeding
that's one issue the other one is that
you know you have a population
uh
problem and let me
explain that real quickly here okay this
is the population problem here you see
the population on earth we're uh almost
8 billion people
apparently according to the latest
numbers we're like
7.9 billion people on the planet okay
okay and uh how much land area is there
well there's about 150 million
kilometers square kilometers
that comes out to around 53 people per
square kilometers
that's a lot of room
if you look at uh
you know if you look at one square
kilometer that's a lot of space and you
can put a lot of people in there
and uh we're saying that the population
on earth is about 53 per kilometer
square
that's uh low density
so you say uh okay so we have a lot of
room on the planet
forget about eight billion we could put
a trillion people on the planet
one trillion people on the planet we
could put many times as many as we have
today
and physically
physically we could fit on the planet
under and that's only on the
land area i remember the
wider areas like 510 million kilometers
square and
uh that's about
two and a half times more
than what the land area is
so
you know assuming we could live on the
oceans as well you know that number 53
uh you know we could put a lot more
people here on the planet
what's the problem here's the problem
problem is that we're all nucleated in
cities we're not uniformly distributed
across the planet
these are the cities with the highest
density on the planet which are big
cities okay these are the big cities
with the highest density okay
and you'll probably see some of your
cities there uh mumbai is the number one
in the planet it's got 14 million people
the last one which i thought was
probably one of the first ones is tokyo
but the only reason for that is tokyo
has been expanding size wise
you know sideways
and so uh that's why they're number 50.
otherwise you know if you go to tokyo
it's a it's an ant hole
okay but here's the issue what did i say
just now 53 people per kilometer squared
and here we're talking about almost 5
000 people per kilometer square in tokyo
all the way to about 30 000 in mumbai
30 000 people per kilometer square
that's what you see in mumbai
these are not the biggest uh these are
not the most uh densely populated cities
on the planet
the these are the uh
here let me show you this
let me get it here
these are the
cities that with the most population
density on the planet they're not the
largest cities okay
and uh they're smaller cities but
they're more densely populated than the
big cities
give me a second here
get this out of the way
okay uh so these are the uh
most densely populated cities they're
not the biggest cities and and again you
can see the numbers uh they're you know
they're in the thousands per kilometer
squared
so what's the issue the issue is that
here is the um
the trend
where is it here
this is the trend for the whole planet
okay
this is uh the growth rate for the
entire planet you can see it's going
down to zero maybe by mid-century
sometime in this century this century
we're not going to have more people
being produced on this planet we're
going down down down down down
since the year 1963.
and why is that so well because when you
move to the cities
families that move to the cities from
the country
they no longer have children
the cities are not placed to have
children no one was going to have 10
children in a family anymore
you can't have 10 children in an
apartment anymore
that was okay in the country our great
grandmothers they had 10 children half
of them died great no problem five of
them continued
that's no longer going to happen
women today many of them don't even want
to have children
and those that do have one or two that's
it
and so when you come to the city for
social and economic reasons no one has
children
so it's it's not a question of either
traveling outside
the you know the earth
uh saying oh i'm gonna colonize uh you
know mars
yeah or the moon no we're not gonna have
children because as you can see in the
graph
we stopped having children and we're
going to have fewer and fewer children
as time goes by from now on
partly because of homosexuality
which is on the rise i'm saying
they're not going to have too many
children or any children at all okay
most of them
then you have
women today they don't want to have
children
you move to the cities you change the
culture you change this social
environment you change the economics
uh you no longer need to
maintain your uh parents
you know the city the estate does that
you don't have to take care of the
children because kindergartners do that
you know it's a state that takes care of
everything
so you know people don't have children
and people seem
bogged down by children they see them as
anchors
i want to go on vacation i can't because
i got the to take care of the children
or the children don't have vacation from
school so i can't go on vacation
and you know people see that the young
people see them say oh i don't think i
want to have children yet
ahem when i'm what 75 years
old so they postpone
they don't have children
then they have them when they're
old and that's when the children come
out [ __ ] as well so
it all works in the worst possible way
so so the issue is we're not going to go
out of the solar system because we don't
need more space it's not like we need to
expand
our population to mars and later to
pluto and then who knows to
alpha centauri and uh to the entire
galaxy
we have more than enough space here on
earth for people
we're not producing people right now
because everybody is moving to these ant
holes called cities and instead of
having 53
people per kilometer square across the
earth what we have is thousands what 30
000 people in a given city because
everybody moves to the city like in
mumbai so everybody moves there and
everybody lives in this ant hole
and when you're in the ant hole you
don't produce children
that's the situation
and so yeah that conduces to a no growth
and it kills the economy because
what is the economy human economy it's
more profits next year more sales next
year
and less costs
what does that mean that you need more
people to buy your things
and
fewer workers
you got to cut down on labor because
that's cost and you have to increase
your sales
that's uh revenue that's that's our
mentality that's our economic system and
what's happening out there is something
different you have fewer people being
born
pure demand being created for the future
and meanwhile yeah the other part is is
on target you know we're producing
uh machines that replace man so we're
having less work
less labor
and fewer customers
that's the situation now you run that to
the future tell me
where that's going to end
okay let's move on to the subject matter
today and that's going to be magnetism
what is magnetism what in the world is
magnets why does a magnet attract
another you know here you have it okay
uh my two
famous uh
clips here
okay
here it is you've seen it here for the
first time in your life okay
now put them closer together and you can
feel the pull there already
magnetism attraction and there you see
it again just in case you missed it
not close enough okay okay
in fact i'll hold it here you'll see it
here okay
i'm not pushing it okay it's pulling
okay
and people say is magnetism a pull yeah
it is a pull nothing's pushing from the
outside it's the pull from the inside
and mathematicians haven't discovered
that in 400 years
so that's unbelievable
okay but we start with a
couple of issues that were left over
from last time because people are not
sure about certain things especially
regarding uh energy this work called
energy which is going to enter the
picture okay
because all these words energy field
magnetism they're all related okay
okay so let's go with this issue and
it's called capacity what is energy it's
capacity
and so you have to define what capacity
is what do you mean by capacity okay so
here it is let's
find out here knowing exactly what
capacity is that's what one file asks or
says
and he points to a
a video there a youtube video
and you go in there and well let me just
analyze that first yeah i always wanted
to know what capacity is i've never seen
one
is this what uh it looks like that's
what energy is in another video from the
establishment okay so is that what
capacity is is that what it looks like
okay i go to this video that this file
points to and uh this is what i find the
main points okay obviously the video is
a little longer than this but this is
what it says says one of the biggest
questions i get asked is about capacity
capacity of in this case he's talking
about a battery okay capacity means the
actual quantity of electricity
quantity of electricity okay
that you can extract out of a battery
so how do we measure capacity
so he immediately moves into measuring
he hasn't really finished with
what quantity of electricity means
and so you're left dangling there like
saying what do you mean by quantity of
electricity what is this like quantity
of water
or a number of apples what are you
talking about what is quantity of
electricity
i mean here you have a breakdown you
look up the word quantity and it says
the property of magnitude something
having magnitude
and you look up magnitude and says a
number characteristic of a quantity
another one of those famous mathematical
circular
definitions yeah you learn nothing from
the mathematicians because they never
never ever defined a single word in
their lexicon okay
okay so uh we have to go with a
common notion of quantity and you find
you know like if you want to say a
quantity of milk what do you say well
one liter okay and that's different uh
than saying one pound of butter for
example and that's cody different than
saying 10 apples in the first case
you're talking about a measurement in
the second case you're talking about
counting so counting is not the same
thing as measuring
and quantity unfortunately has not been
defined properly and it could refer to
either a measurement or counting
so that's where the problem starts okay
now you can count meters you can count
dreams if you're counting dreams what
are you going to count i mean are you
going to say i'm going to
weigh the dreams or
you know say how many atoms are in there
now you say i had eight dreams last
night that's how you say it okay
electricity is measured in amps
so
electricity you can't say well you had
eight amps
meaning eight units
eight
objects
no amps is a measurement so when you say
three amps you're really referring to a
measurement same with voltage and same
with watts for power you're talking
about a measurement not a uh you're not
counting you're measuring okay and you
use this measure
called amps in the case of electricity
and that's what you're going to use
so what is quantity of electricity well
you're saying three amps what is three
amps well it's something you measure
in this case it's going to be the flow
allegedly the flow of charges
that's what they're gonna come down to
okay and are you gonna count the charges
and say i had five charges
now you're gonna say i had five amps
which is different than saying i had you
know um five charges
or five electron balls beads or whatever
so keep this in mind we're gonna look at
you know uh units here okay are we gonna
count units or measure them
and this fellow points me to a site
where where it shows that electricity is
treated as a physical object
you go to the site and this is what you
see you see a fellow in there and he
says look i have this quantity of
electricity
and he puts water in a bag and says
assume that's 10 000 watts of
electricity
he's going to treat electricity as a
bunch of water
as a physical object
he's going to take these weights which
he's going to say well imagine that is a
battery and one is a 12 volt battery
battery and the other one is 120 volt
battery okay
and he's just just going to put these
weights on top of these wider bags that
contain so much water so much
electricity that's the analogy and he's
gonna then pinch them and gonna say look
more water comes out of the one that's
got the heavier weight than the one and
the
weaker weight on the you know the
lighter weight
okay so this is the analogy he's
treating electricity as a physical
object he's saying
electricity is like
that's what he's saying
and if you and uh voltage is like a
weight
and if you put a bigger weight
on one of them you're gonna get more
electricity out of that bag
okay so he's treating electricity as a
physical object that's the notion people
have that uh
voltage
is some kind of potential difference in
this case
measured by these weights okay
and uh electricity is the water that
comes that flows because of this
difference in potential
and again that's a wrong notion because
like i said last week if that were the
case if uh if if it has to do with
pressure if it has to do with
difference in potential as they say one
potential higher the other one lower
then what are we saying that the
electron beads
roll down an inclined plane from high to
low
and that's the analogy for electricity
that you have the water tank above the
other water tank below and water flows
downwards we can all understand that
because it's gravity
is that what we're saying electricity is
high to low
well that's very simple you put the
terminals in the opposite direction you
put the one that was low now you put it
higher the other one lower
will the electrons flow the other
direction
and the answer is no
you know so so the analogy is bunk is
nonsense
you know this this analogy high to low
because that's gravity that's not
electricity
okay that's not how electricity works it
doesn't work on high to low
difference in potential levels
uh that notion it doesn't work that way
so you have to come up with a better
analogy for what voltage is
you know this difference in potential
what do you really mean and this guy
said you know i put two weights on these
bags of electricity
yeah sure
so he's treating electricity as a
physical object when electricity is not
you know they say it's the flow of
electron beads and last week we showed
that it's not in other words we argued
that the electron bead model doesn't
work first of all because you cannot
imagine
the planetary model on which it's based
you cannot imagine why that electron
bead rolls around the nucleus without
falling to it or flying outside of that
system
why do we have a planetary model of the
atom
which has been debunked anyways by the
main but same quantum people they say
that's not the model
so why do they teach that model why did
they use that even as an analogy if
that's not the case give me the real
model
the super duper
quantum model of universities that's the
one i want to see
they don't have one
even in the universities they use the
planetary model
and the planetary model is bunk but they
use it anyway because they have no other
model
and they use the electron as a bead
and yeah when you use a voltage when you
try to explain voltage you have to
explain it with a bead and you say all
these beads roll down because there's a
difference in potential high to low
is that what electricity is are the
little beads rolling down an inclined
plane
and if we put them in the opposite
direction we show that's not the case
so the analogy is nonsense and the
planetary model of the atom is nonsense
you can't use the electron bead as a
model
because that model has been debunked you
cannot rationalize it
okay
so anyone using the bead model the
that electricity is the flow of electron
beads is talking nonsense
okay electricity is not
the flow of electron beads because you
cannot justify that model because you
cannot justify the planetary model of
the atom to begin with
i hope that's clear
okay so you got to start there you got
to show me your atom before you talk
about electron beads flowing okay that's
where we start
okay
along the same lens
fella says i got attacked for saying
photons were light
poor fallow
i was told this is wrong
can you clarify
is the electromagnetic spectrum a total
fraud
okay uh and so this is my quick answer
they should not attack you okay whoever
did that is a meanie
they should treat you with the respect
that you deserve okay
you're not wrong
okay i'm i'm on record you say i was
told this is wrong you're not wrong okay
i'm on record
the electromagnetic spectrum is not a
fraud at all
okay
okay so here's my answer to that my real
answer okay
you're not wrong you're irrational
the photon is not an object
the photon is a concept
photon is a wave function collapse
whatever that means to you okay
particles cannot explain any phenomenon
or property of light not one okay
particles cannot explain anything about
light so anyone using discrete particles
is talking nonsense
aside from the fact that the so-called
particle of quantum mechanics is not a
particle this is not a corpuscle it's
not a speck of dust a grain of sand the
particle quantum mechanics is a wave
function that collapse it's a number
okay it's a function
an equation
i don't know how else to tell you okay
that somehow collapsed physically
collapsed to a point
is that point a
dot uh
i mean what is it is it a
so-called photon are we talking again
about a grain of sand no we're talking
about a nothing we're talking about a
number that collapse whatever that means
okay
and then you cannot simulate wavelength
with discrete particles anyone using
particles uh we call them an idiot
meaning
a person with big ideas
he doesn't have normal ideas he has
ideoths and so we call them idiots
anyways the spectrum is the graph of
different lengths of
um
links of the electromagnetic rope and
there you see them okay at the top but
these people think that it's
i guess the thickness or the width
of a photon which is a particle
so i don't know how you can simulate
wavelength or link length
with photons with photon particles
discrete beads
do they have different sizes is that
what their people these people are
proposing
okay so yeah
the the particle model is bunk it's
nonsense anyone proposing particles
should be executed period
okay
they should not be around anymore okay
anyone proposing particles simply as
talking nonsense you cannot explain a
single phenomenon of nature the
invisible stuff intangible stuff with
particles okay
okay so uh what is this magnetism thingy
okay and here we go to live science and
essentially everybody says the same
thing so i chose one at random i chose
life science follow writes in there what
is magnetism okay what is it magnetic
fields and magnetic force
okay let's see what he has to say he
says
magnetism refers to physical phenomena
arising from the force caused by magnets
aha yeah okay
objects that produce fields
okay
that attract or repel other objects
fields that attract and repel
what is this field thingy i wonder a
magnetic field exerts a force on a
particles in the field due to the
lorentz force
that you see there on the right okay
according to georgia state university
hyperphysics website which is where that
graph on the
or that picture on the right it comes
from
okay so uh the guy's just relying i
guess on authority saying oh i just go
by what the georgia state university
tells us okay great
the motion of electrically charged
particles gives rise to magnetism
okay so we have electrically charged
particles and that's what gives rise to
magnetism so what is this lawrence force
well it's just an equation
it's just a description mathematical
description so as you take the electric
force plus the magnetic force and that's
the force the lorentz force great
we learned a lot
so
this force this is what becomes the
field which is what moves objects around
what is this fieldy thing
okay
that's what we want to get to the bottom
of because they're going to use this
word field
to say why a magnet attracts another
they're going to explain magnetism with
this word field
that's what you got to keep in mind so
we're gonna have to get to the bottom of
this word field
okay so
fellow says magnetic fields are
generated by rotating electric charges
okay so we have rotating magnetic char
electric charges
okay and what he's talking about he's
talking about electrons that are moving
again he's going to think of this as
electric beads or electron beads okay
and he's going to call them electric
charges because the electron carries
like we said the other day it carries
1.6 times 10 to the minus 19 coulombs of
charge
okay
and says electrons all have a property
of angular momentum or spin so these
charges these electron beads they spin
around
okay and there you see them spinning
okay
most electrons trying to form pairs in
which one of them is spin up and the
other is spin down in this case their
magnetic fields are in opposite
directions so they cancel each other out
okay
okay
however some atoms contain one or more
unpaired electrons which spin can
produce a directional magnetic field
which you see there okay the magnetic
field
okay whatever that is i tried to
you know illustrate that as best as
possible
the direction of their spin determines
the direction of the magnetic field
when a significant majority of unpaired
electrons are aligned with their spins
in the same direction they combine to
produce a magnetic field that is strong
so this is it
there's you see it you see why a magnet
attracts another they say the electrons
spin apparently in the same direction
and if they spin in the same direction
they create this magnetic field each one
each each magnet creates this magnetic
field and if they're in the same
direction they kind of um
you know uh sympathize with each other
and they attract each other that's it
and if you turn them around obviously
the magnetic fields are facing each
other and they push each other away
so again we need to get to the bottom of
this magnetic field because this is what
they're going to use to explain
you know magnetism they're going to
explain how a magnet attracts another
with these fields
okay let me get this out of here
okay so there you see it what is the
official version
is you have
on the north or south of the magnet the
electrons that form the atoms that are
part of these uh regions okay
uh
they spin in the same direction
and so their fields they create fields
that are somehow
i don't know exactly how how to
visualize it again that's the best i
could do is show you that the fields are
out there these
numbers floating around
and they're going the right same
direction
and somehow those fields produce
attraction but we still don't understand
the mechanism the physical mechanism
especially if the fields are just a
bunch of numbers
okay and so what is a field okay
let's find out now we looked at this the
other day let's go over this again a
field is a quantity
it's a number a bunch of numbers
actually represented by a number that
has a value for each point in space time
space and time
so we have number what is number uh
mathematical object
object uh used to count measure and
label okay so it's a number it's an
abstraction
value any definite mathematical object
again right most often a number meaning
another mathematical object that
measures and labels okay so it's just
we have abstraction so far no physical
object
point it's an exact location
what is space and time any mathematical
model which
uh fuses the three dimensions of space
and one dimension of time
what is the diam what is space it's a
fundamental space
and when it's time is a concept that
means uh the continued sequence of
existence
what do we have so far nothing
so far all we have is abstractions
and with this abstraction they're going
to produce a real result in the physical
world which is attraction between two
tangible magnets
in other words here we have right
okay so this is tangible it's c of all
right you have two magnets there right
in the center the black
around things there
and they attract each other and they're
saying that's done by what a field which
is a number which is a quantity which is
i'm sorry a value which is a point which
is another abstraction which is space
and time which are concepts
this is done by absolute
concepts that's the explanation that's
the official explanation
so yeah we have a little bit of problem
with all this because they're saying you
know they're you're asking for a
physical interpretation how does a
magnet attract another what is magnetism
and they're saying it's an abstraction
it's all caused by these numbers that we
have floating around in space
that are created by
uh electrons which are spinning
and those electrons are beads that
belong to the planetary atom which is
bunk
bunk according not to bill gatey they're
bunk according to the establishment
they say no no that's not our matter
so why do you teach it in high school
well we teach it there because it's the
simplest way to teach this stuff to the
kids who are coming up to speed
why don't you teach them the real adam
well because the real adam the one
they teach at the university level is
the same atom that they teach at the
high school level which is the planetary
model of neospore which hasn't changed
in over 100 years
we still have the same planetary model
in mathematical physics okay so that's
the situation
okay
here to make matters worse it doesn't
stop there with magnetism we have
another issue to resolve and that's this
that with magnetism there are north and
south poles this is from a site and they
all say the same thing i just pulled one
out similar to charge like magnetic
poles repel each other while unlike
poles attract
okay so we have light poles that
uh
repel and unlike poles attract and we
call them north and south poles we have
no idea what's happening at the north or
south poles i guess uh
the way i put it there the north pole
has santa claus
especially now that christmas came
around i thought about sani
and uh the south pole has the norwegian
flag if it doesn't have the norwegian
flag on it you have to doubt whether
it's the south pole
and you say well why the norwegian flag
well that's because roald amundsen you
know he's the guy i think it was 1912.
he's the guy who discovered the south
pole just like columbus discovered
america
he's the guy who got there first
in front of robert scott
who
died in his attempt to reach the south
pole he reached it a little late started
earlier but
reached there later
and uh rolled almonds and beat him
because he went there with these huskies
you know dogs who were used to the cold
the other guy brought horses and
tractors and who knows what spent a lot
of money and died in the effort
so yeah if you don't see the
norwegian flag you don't know if it's a
south pole okay let's make that clear
and the north pole is the one that's got
santa in it that's all we know about the
north and south pole what is this north
south
positive negative
what do those mean physically what is
the physical
meaning of these terms
okay
no mother nature understands something
else and it's known as clockwise and
counterclockwise
and here you have the mechanism this is
a mechanism
okay
it's not for you to believe it's for you
to understand
okay and we're saying is that when a
magnet is has two up when two magnets
have opposite
polarities
you know uh
so they attract each other and when they
have similar ones they repel each other
why well you can see it here if they
have opposite polarities their threads
are swinging in the same direction and
if you turn them sideways again they're
swinging in the same direction only when
you switch them 180 degrees do they
repel each other because now they
the threads swing in opposite directions
very simple mechanism a kindergartener
can understand this
and the assumption is that all um atoms
are swinging which are aligned in those
uh magnets
are swinging the threads in a given
direction that's all that's the only
assumption you have to make and that's
and those lines of force that um
what's his name um
michael faraday discovered
uh those lines of force are those uh
threads that are swinging around
so what's happening is the iron filings
align
along those lines of force
okay
and uh
so that ends the notion of magnetism
okay let's get on with
the questions people asked last uh time
around
and comments people made here's the one
fellow says what novel prediction
predictions can you make from your
theory any novel observations as well
uh
what can we say you know
this guy thinks science is about
astrology or or gawking you confuse
astrology and palm reading with science
that's your problem okay you're asking a
question that's irrational we don't do
predictions in science we don't do
observations okay we do not prophecy we
do not gawk okay that's not part of
science
and you know experiments uh
doing an experiments and observing what
happened
you know that's not science imagine
imagine you go to the lab like in high
school they do that a lot they do that
also in in
college
uh you go to a lab chemistry lab
and they pour in a
you know flask or a test tube they put
some red liquid
you know and you see it there okay
and now they pour some
grains of whatever
and turns blue
so you did an experiment
you observed
okay you did both those things
did you do science
i mean what are you going to tell
the crowd you're going to say oh i've
got this red liquid i turn it into blue
and i turn the blue liquid into red
and
and here's the experiment and i hope you
observed it
is that science
or is science explaining why how
that red liquid turned into blue and
vice versa
is that science or or is is just running
the experiment and observing and not
understanding how that happened
is that science which one is science
so no observation and experiments have
nothing to do with science neither is
prediction
so what are you going to do next you're
gonna say hey you know
watch closely i'm gonna make a
prediction i'm gonna throw these little
grains this little stuff
inside the red liquid and i'm gonna turn
it into blue
why because you did it in the
lab you know several times you know
that's what's going to happen so you say
i can predict i know
what do you know well i know the red
liquid is going to turn into blue and
everybody says let's see prove it and
the guy does it and proves it oh he did
magic
he's a scientist
and he did it in so much time what few
seconds he can even put that down and
say
it happens in three seconds
is that science
or his science explaining
the mechanism of how the red liquid
turned into blue why it turned into blue
there's a difference
science is the second one is explaining
but observing doing experiment observing
and making predictions because you saw
the effect many times that's not science
that's gawking
okay so don't ask
us to gawk
okay you can continue gawking if you
want
okay another person asks
he says i'm confused by your position on
relativity okay you say that the theory
of relativity is correct
no i
don't you say that the speed of light is
indeed constant yes i do
on the other hand you uh goof all about
time dilation space contraction
space-time curvature yeah
okay given the theory of relativity the
curvature of space-time and the warping
of space and time aren't necessary
correlates uh of the constant speed of
light how do you square the seeming
contradictions
well this fellow doesn't understand what
the theory of relativity says that's
that's the issue
what is a theory
is a theory a description which is what
this spell is describing in the last
couple paragraphs here or sentences
no theory is an explanation let's get
that straight we're not concerned about
the math we're not concerned about the
descriptions
we want to understand what the theory is
what the mechanism is of gravity
and for that you need physical objects
what's the problem with general
relativity
there are no objects in relativity
that's the problem
okay there's no sun or earth there's no
moon
there's no jupiter no pluto
there are masses
they don't talk about objects they talk
about masses
that's the first one you to understand
the second one is they talk about space
and time
and they say
we have this mass
and it sits on space time because they
fuse these two concepts together
so we have the concept mass sitting on
the concept space time
and you say what is space time well
don't even try to imagine it because
it's four dimensional
so it's unimaginable
yeah any concept is unimaginable you
cannot make an image
of four-dimensional space-time above any
or of any concept you cannot even make
an image of mass
energy field
time force all those concepts you cannot
make an image of you cannot picture them
you cannot
turn them into physical objects
so these people are talking about
abstractions and that's how they're
going to explain
the mechanism of gravity that's the
physical interpretation they're going to
give you
and so yeah here we have
the problem okay you can see it here
relativity is not correct it's
irrational
okay so it's it's not an issue that it's
uh correct it's that it's irrational
unimaginable for the space time is
irrational okay
and why is it irrational because there
is no physical object called space time
there's no physical object that is four
dimensional okay
and time is a concept so
to say four dimensional time
or that time is one dimensional or that
time is a dimension or has dimension
that's irrational
time is not a dimension okay time is a
number line that the mathematicians use
okay and
even in the number line it has no
direction but they put an arrow at the
end of it so time is completely screwed
up time is simply a number line that's
all it is number lines don't have
direction
okay so that's the problem there but
then uh we have little c yeah it's a
constant
travels at 300 000 kilometers per second
more or less okay
and but little c is not a theory
okay there is no theory called 300 000
kilometers per second so the fact that
light travels at a constant speed is
irrelevant that's
you can say it's an assumption necessary
to move on to the theory to explain
something with that speed
or with that constancy of that speed why
is it constant that's where the theory
comes in that's that's where the
explanation comes in
so theory is gravity according to
relativity uh is gravity is warped space
time that's what the theory of
relativity says
and there you see it at the bottom they
say that
the earth doesn't leave the solar system
because time is a wall
of
wall of time right that
comes up against the skin of the earth
because that's the explanation they give
you for why the earth doesn't fly out of
the solar system that it's like a little
ball on a roulette it just goes around
and around because it's going against
the wall
created by the warpage of space-time
created by the sun the sun ways down
space-time creates this
in
this depression
and then the earth has no way of leaving
the depression because it runs up
against the wall it rolls up around the
wall what is the wall made out of that
wall that's warped time
that's the physical interpretation that
general relativity gives people don't
like to hear they say no that's not what
relativity says yes that is that is what
relativity says i'm sorry to tell you
give me the physical interpretation of
quantum
general relativity
otherwise
okay and uh the theory earth does not
exit solar system because time is work
that's what they say you don't like it
uh
you say that's wrong that's not what
relativity says tell me what what it
does say
let's find out what it in other words i
want the physical interpretation of
gravity the physical interpretation
don't give me any numbers don't give me
any equations
i don't want to hear that i want the
physic i want objects
i want to know why the earth doesn't
want to fly that doesn't fly out of the
solar system
and give me a physical interpretation
what physical object prevents the earth
from flying out of the solar system and
relativity says there's a warp wall of
space time in other words i don't care
about the space part because people get
confused about whether space is a
physical object or not it's easier to
deal with warped time if time is worked
you got a problem you got a mental
problem because time is a concept you
can't say that time is warped like a
banana that a second is warped like a
banana
and that's what relativity is
insinuating more than xenia that's that
is the theory for why the earth doesn't
leave the solar system
okay so yeah i'm going to fight that to
the end so you better get uh
the correct theory
and explain it in
luxury of detail okay if you think that
that's not what relativity says
okay another issue val says object that
which you can imagine or draw he's got
all these definitions okay that he put
out there concept a derogatory
form used to degrade alternate
hypothesis
i love that one
so we use the word concept to
to insult people to
to kill their theories
but then he says object and concepts are
synonyms now that i don't understand an
object is that which you can imagine or
draw
and again we have problems there because
he introduces you meaning a person a
human
and that's already an object so an
object requires another object to be
able to define
and then you gotta draw it which is a
verb and verbs come
after objects first you have to have a
an object in order to have motion
and so verbs always uh have to be
defined after defining the word object
in physics
and but that's not the problem the
bigger problem is that he says it's a
synonym of concept and what is
constantly the derogatory
uh way of uh degrading alternate
hypothesis
[Laughter]
so i guess the poor fellow must be very
frustrated
okay anyways universe a set of objects
that have physical presence with each
other
no mention of space
it's just that uh
says that deals with objects uh i guess
the universe is just the objects no
space in there
no uh universe is objects and space
that's what the the word universe means
okay at least in rational science and
essentially that's what everybody out
there also believes uh the word universe
means we just don't pay attention to the
word universe because it's a concept
first of all there's no physical object
called universe because it's it includes
both the objects meaning primarily the
stars planets and asteroids etc all the
atoms gases
and space
that's it
that's
this these two groups matter and space
that's what forms the word universe
and this person says it's just what the
set of objects
okay
of course he's got irrational
definitions he's got the wrong
foundations for any theory that come
that he
found
you know places upon them
okay motion two or more locations of an
object what is time the same thing to
have more than one location
so for him time and motion are synonyms
yeah all the irrational definitions and
then he says rational religious term
used to label motions bill uh notions
bill uh supports
now we have a definition for the word
rational we define that several times
okay
and the main one there is that if you
reify objects if you turn a concept into
an object that is primarily the the
number one
criteria for what is irrational there
are a couple others undefined words or
words that are used inconsistently okay
and that the uh
the theory doesn't follow from the
hypothesis from the assumptions
you know i give the example that uh the
prosecutor presents a gun
and then his theory has to do about
poisoning you know the person who died
uh one doesn't follow from the
uh what he presented as exhibit one you
know that sort of thing so there are
different criteria for what is
irrational we have it very clear for
physics okay and the main one is again
turning concepts into objects which is
what mathematical physics has done for
the last 400 years
field force
uh
what is it wave
ether all these
you know all these concepts have been
turned into physical objects that's
where the problem is
okay another issue falsehood so when you
say that every atom is connected to
every other atom do you mean that any
single atom is directly connected to
every atom in the universe
yes
exactly you got it right
that's a large amount of ropes coming
out of a single atom equal to the number
of atoms that there are minus one to be
exact yeah
not sure if that's what you mean can you
go into
this some more yeah
you said it all correctly i i
verify i
confirm
everything that you just said okay
one atom is connected to every atom in
the universe in our universe there could
be a parallel universe i always give
that possibility meaning that every atom
in that other universe is not connected
with their ropes to our universe meaning
that we would not be able to see
or touch any of those atoms maybe touch
we would i don't know this is again
speculation meaning that if one of those
universes came across our universe you
suddenly would
have something come through the wall
that you can't see or touch
or at least you can't see maybe you can
touch it but not see it okay but no the
the issue here is that um
we're saying that there's a single
thread that underlies all matter
and interconnecting ropes
in the universe
all atoms are interconnected by ropes
all of it is made by a single thread
that
uh weaves all of it okay all around the
universe so we're connected to
everything physically
and uh so here it is
here's the answer okay
uh what we have is mr fineman and he
gives you an idea because you have this
large amount and this is what feynman
says he said the gravitational
attraction relative to the electrical
repulsion between two electrons is one
divided by four times ten to the
uh twenty what forty second okay the
question is where does such a large
number come from
he could never figure that out
and the answer is yeah we have a lot of
ropes even that number i'm not sure if
if you could
you know uh put your hand in the fire
for that but yeah
when you're talking about uh atoms in
the room in this room
we got gazillions of atoms
uncountable
not to mention the number of atoms
that form the solar system the earth the
solar system
the galaxy and the universe
you're talking about lots of atoms
and the first question is
why don't you ask that question in
quantum
why don't you ask that question in
general relativity
nobody asks those questions over there
there are so many particles in the
universe yeah
even under quantum mechanics you have
gazillions of particles in fact you have
more than in the rope model
because under quantum mechanics under
general relativity space itself is made
out of particles
so if you include all those particles of
space and there is more space and matter
in the universe
well i don't know you figure out how
many particles there are in the universe
at least we cut it down a little bit and
say look space is not made out of
particles it's only matter that's made
out of particles
out of uh
right
and um
and it's all made for a single thread so
the thread only includes matter it
doesn't include space like it does in
the religion of quantum mechanics
general relativity so whenever you say
are there that many atoms
first ask that question of quantum
mechanics
see all these people want to ask these
questions about the rope model they say
how can a rope go through another rope
and they never ask that question of
quantum mechanics how can a particle go
through another particle in quantum
mechanics
how does energy go through energy
you know you take two laser pointers you
cross them across the
lights and they go right through each
other
nobody asks the questions how can they
go through each other
i mean those physical entities you can
see them
and i'm sure if you point the laser
enough at your hand you'll probably burn
a hole in it if the laser's
uh strong enough
so it's a physical object that it's
coming out of that laser
of some kind
it's got at least it has a physical um
influence over your hand which is made
out of atoms
and then you take these two lasers and
you can cross them right through each
other
and they don't get deflected or you know
the particles get scattered or anything
and nobody asks the question nobody
nobody nobody asks even questions how
that can possibly be the case how can
light go through light
nobody asks that question
but when i say the rope go through each
other how can the rope go through each
other
well the rope is light
and and we gotta explain how light goes
through light so the rope had better go
through the rope
and you say but how can a rope go
through another rope
well because an object is not that which
you can see or touch an object is that
which has shape not all objects can be
seen
not all objects can be touched
period
okay so until you understand that unless
you get that under your skin
uh you're gonna be rolling in the uh in
your sleep all night okay
okay final issue fall says
bill said all objects uh are made of
shape and space
made of shape and space
i don't know what these people think you
know they understand everything
it's
irrational manners they're having
irrational brains that's what they have
and they understand everything wrong so
they want to reword it and they reword
it wrong
they don't understand what i'm saying
every object is surrounded by space
yeah
if you can say surrounded by space what
i'm saying space serves as a backdrop
that's the best way to put it uh but
yeah you could say surrounded by space
but space is nothing there is no
surrounding object
space is nothing and this guy can't get
this through his thick skull every atom
is contoured
uh encapsulated by space yeah
in other words what we're saying is
space is nothing space is that what does
nothing mean nothing is that which
doesn't have shape
so you can't say space is a thing
okay there is no such thing as space
space is not thing
no thing nothing okay
and it serves as the backdrop to
anything
in other words if you have an atom
what contours it it we call that space
that black stuff and there you see it
god creates an object okay
and uh
we call it object x
it's got a shape we don't know what it
is we don't care it's an object because
it has shape
and it's got to have something
contouring it otherwise that thing would
be
you know an enormous block in an
infinite block
of whatever
if it didn't have that black stuff all
around it
and thanks to that black stuff which we
call space that thing is limited
it has shape
even god has shaped thanks to that black
stuff called space
without that space that nothing that
black stuff
god would be an infinite block of
whatever whatever you want to call it x
so uh yeah space contours every object
specifically it contours every atom
specifically it contours every rope now
the guy said you know if the ropes are
so many there wouldn't be any space now
hopefully space contours every rope in
the universe
for otherwise you would not even imagine
a rope the rope would be a single block
infinite block of whatever
and so yeah space is necessary in order
to distinguish
objects
so there had better be space meaning it
ain't there because it's nothing it
serves as a backdrop space is that which
doesn't have shape
we'll see you next time what is it on
sunday and if i don't see you then uh
merry christmas we'll see you then bye
bye